give me your perspective on arthur is he
a villain
no he's trying to heal the world and
everybody thinks it's so easy to heal
the world i'm trying to purge the world
of sin brother
um
you don't want sinners around you do you
come on that must be very difficult
[Music]
a voice in your head
this chaos in you
i mean i guess it depends on what kind
of sin
i think that uh you know
certainly
that
perspective is one of the ones that
gives the marvel some of the marvel
villains
it makes them incredibly interesting is
that they have these altruistic ends
they want good things they just go about
them by degrees of
villainy i suppose right
yeah when you take anything to the
extreme it kind of becomes evil you know
you take idealism to some ridiculous
point when you constantly think the ends
justify the means then you start
turning into a villain
yeah were there any other of these
marvel villains that you had seen that
when oscar approached you about doing
this you thought oh maybe this might not
just be the kind of like typical comic
book though there might be a chance to
do something really interesting with it
yeah i mean it's scary because
there's some people that have done
really great work creating diabolical
villains in the past you know i i think
of vincent d'onofrio as fisk and
daredevil and and a handful of others
and i really worried i knew i wasn't
going to be able to contribute on that
level and i
what was fun about
moon knight was that they don't
have
the comics don't present with an obvious
spoil for moon egg they have lots of
different
bad guys but there's not the iconic
bad guy the way that some superheroes
have a villain that's very as iconic as
the hero is
so i knew we had to create somebody
and i knew that it would be challenging
because
he couldn't be crazy because the hero is
suffering from mental illness
i needed to present something that would
maybe be in opposition to him and what's
the most terrifying thing to an insane
person is somebody who's sane like a
doctor or
you know somebody who knows the truth
and is balanced that's very threatening
to an unbalanced person and uh so that's
how what i built it on and i just
tried not to think about it like in
generic like i want to be a good villain
i needed to be
the antagonist in this story and just
try to make moon knight as good as
possible what do you think from arthur's
perspective what's his take on
konchu and and and ahmet we learned some
interesting things about arthur and his
relationship to kanchu early on in the
in the season yeah you learned that i
was i was moon knight before he was and
that i hated it and i didn't want to be
that
and i
really didn't trust kanchu
and so
i think
one of the struggles that
mark stephen has to figure out as he
understands his role in these powers
that he has is how to use them and
can his
god be trusted does arthur think his god
can be trusted yeah he's a fervent
believer he's a front you know that's
the problem you know once you go down
the rabbit hole you he's doubled down on
ahmet he believes in that crocodile
whole hog
yeah oh my god you're alive what's wrong
with you mark
why did you call me mark what was your
reaction to watching oscar portray this
character with the two personalities you
know that's the fun of performing over a
lifetime is to watch when when i just
get really excited about a part and
somebody really pours themselves into it
good things happen you know it's like
watching somebody jump off a high dive
or something you know like when they've
got the guts to do it
and and they've got the brains and
discipline to really work at how to do
it well it's exciting to be around
watching somebody work that hard and how
about your reaction to seeing him in his
full
super suit he's got two of them was
there was there a moment we were like oh
man i want a super suit no
i mean
yes maybe now that you think of it
uh now that you say it like that
but no i really just felt it's the first
time you realize oh right because you
get obsessed with the script and the
story and wanting to tell it well and
and then when he walks in that suit
you're like oh right we're making a
superhero movie it all becomes really
real and yeah i probably had a little
stroke of the green monster envy
seeing how good he looked in that suit
and the way all the girls reacted to him
lots of swooning
[Music]